[Music]
hey what's going on start it up
Oh start it up what what what what what
what some another episode of the hands
around with podcast on the air hair over
on Fairmont and vocals you you will use
its Tony trend on weed vocals and what's
good mood and then we have special guest
second time on the show you might have
heard it on the live episode beautify
Southwest yeah Byron Bowers here by
having balance through bone
that's not straighten out a little bit
before we get all the way to where
Byron Bowers in the shine I'm in the
shower baby and also in the side I'm
innocent
but you guys should switch patches so we
could tell which one's this theremin is
which are we below five you guys are on
the same preset oh let me get out I know
I did mother sale there you go yeah
yours are the squeaky line alright
alright anyway so you hit your hair
suiting the enjoy what you have filming
up television show yeah can't attend
shooting in the sides to subsidence yeah
that's true yeah after going off the
last few days yeah the fireworks were
getting to me I didn't like it
what I was hit is right it is explosive
one on one almost hit us what was hit in
the patio that bar one which came across
and it got a bit it got a bit dicey it's
terrible we made first day of shooting
today today when I first did not was my
second time shooting second time and
Chicago shooting a television show yeah
I was a tourist the first time I walked
around Navy Pier yeah with the Garrett's
got a handful of cheese popcorn just a
handful no napkins no I ordered the
small yeah but I didn't get napkins for
some reason and I'm walking like two
miles with a cheesy half hand yes it can
get it can get dicey with that [ __ ] you
enjoy it what's the big deal about that
[ __ ] everybody Ellen what's the big deal
was a good it's pretty good
I'm not one I want to shout out their
business it's just I think some stuff
just catches on it is pretty good for
popcorn if you're in the popcorn yeah
it's good it's really good popcorn you
hear a hotel it's just right when you
get off the plane no clothes on you see
people lined up to get popcorn it's
weird but look at the flavors they got
cheese but her milk caramel so you can
make anything other than the ten this is
the same [ __ ] what this thing it is the
thing I guess I'm just hating all right
man get your money Garrett's snow cones
all right have one of those snow cone a
the mother can joints not light on the
snow at all they ran out of
no heavy night yeah oh it was heavy on
the dude heavy on the Jew heavy on that
color Turner
yeah that's Cyril you get a Mexican
vendors not little two white girls is
out by the bridge yeah seven dollars now
thirty one of the organic snow cones
hey dogs yeah organic made from only
natural
sugary yes ingredients smoker MN just
kind of a recap a ketchup episode man
had lost [ __ ] going on where happen what
a lot of [ __ ] don't know it's all types
of [ __ ] you were just in my city right I
was just in yeah I was in Atlanta
you had a black month this month a very
a lot of the New Orleans for a success
yeah yeah how much happier did you smell
this week you know what I just I I
didn't remember the Aires but here's
what I did you know what I said I'm
doing the movie in Atlanta
I usually my move the movies I've done
is quick rolls and [ __ ] so they might
have a barbarian for one day or whatever
but you know since I'm a lead they bring
in the barber or somebody every other if
somebody looking at my head every day
and so it's just woman I just seems like
all your scalp is kind of dry and so
then somebody's looking at my head every
day I went and got like a special
shampoo I went to Walgreens that's as
far from my hotel Walgreens in Atlanta
the hair products that the black hair
product session is is crazy huge and
they still call it special hair products
but that's not special in Atlanta that's
hair yeah that's true
it's special isn't it if it's Atlanta
this is the norm yeah the black is the
norm but it's still wall green so they
call it special here even though it's
all types of this wonderful moisturizers
and different during that several into I
want to sample it was too late so they
already thought I was still in anyway
because I you know I'd be looking a lot
of times even if I know where I'm going
I look lost
thank you Chim Chim and you in a city
where people still have giri's
yes that's a necessity yeah the condoms
ain't got locks on them with their
Haggar ease kind of thing I'd like some
it's a but in space so Lou is wearing on
me I think got you know what I got to
get my therapy in the green room and get
get the market because the green room it
being too much downtime man and I think
I probably need early if I was able to
do that during my downtime I'll be I was
feeling real lazy take that one back
with you just take a quick hey mo gave
us boat gave us one with with the case
VIN early do you know all your lives now
or do you like you still have to like no
isn't ensemble so so far I have the I
look ahead at them but you know they
sent him the day before and then a lot
of times is everybody has line so it's
not a heavy thing okay and then a lot of
times my shot is not up first as to why
or it's a mic so I get a couple times to
get it right before they move in on my
coverage by the time they come in on my
coverage overcoat I didn't said it
enough times and then I got it so yeah I
don't come in that prep like maybe I
think maybe later I have some stuff
there's a heavier or just more dialogue
heavy that I might have to prep for I
prep a little bit but you can get it
there like it's time just because like I
said is those three hours in the green
room yeah it's time so it's not like
class where or like a test well and I
got to get this because you you know you
have the rehearsal usually before even
between rehearsing and actual shooting
is an hour some usually true so it's
time to learn that [ __ ] our hurts today
just go in just will
setup then we did lunch where they said
a steak and potatoes yeah and then we
supposed to shoot immediately after that
it is full speed yeah not gonna happen
that's bad yeah that's bad management
right there yeah can't get somebody meat
and potatoes weber be doing alive and
it's just a head that's too much too
much weight in your stomach to do
anything you got to take a slight nap or
relax for a second like some people
really dream of acting ladies and
gentlemen yeah me and handle are in [ __ ]
now never dreamed of it at all it was a
condom but not like you guys think
you'll be in a trailer for three hours
that wasn't part of the dream that's
what I was when we and this other actors
were standing around just doing a born
st. not a boring scene is just when we
look around the corner and they zoom in
on us but we just look but we have been
waiting around for hours and I said hi
that's the part you don't you don't call
home tell your parents about this part
yeah my mom's are standing around doing
actually I did tell my friends about it
today I was like yes it's getting kind
of boring there once I bring my Thurman
back she's gonna be waving just don't
bring my salmon that [ __ ] go get crazy
gonna be
[Music]
but yeah man how you feelin with Hermes
anyway why what is this come from why
who introduce y'all to the idea and I
don't you end up with two of well first
of all I'm saying what I omitted in
Chinese being that it became an
obsession - because I have a three and
uh you got three of them yeah we got
four now technically because we got the
real one - folks and me the real like
would joint yeah he's like yo this is
just out in my room this is a this is a
real theorem yeah somebody what's the
other two things out is who these are I
want to describe it like the automated
ones
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah but uh so yeah I really
start is that a couple questions ago I
was just on Twitter while also doing my
Christmas shopping on Amazon and [ __ ]
everyone and I was just joking about oh
maybe I should buy my dad a beat machine
the idea what if I bought my dad a beat
machine and then he just started me
making bangers for Young Jeezy hey you
can i doesn't appraise that's a funny of
my dad with your game I got three souls
on the new GV project that's relaxing
yeah I imagine and so I'm just tweeting
jokes about what should I buy my nieces
and nephews for Christmas it was
actually a really fun way to the
Christmas shop and I probably do it this
year too and so somebody say you should
get them a theremin so I looked it up
and then I bought them a theremin I
bought them and then and then uh I got a
yeah I got my other needs me I got the
one too so I want to theremins I found
out they're not then Toni like you'll
wish use a theremin on a podcast and
then I hit up my sister instead of just
because you know my cheapness and
instead of just buying another one made
up my sister say hey do they still use
that there and she said nope I said send
that [ __ ] to mama house and she said it
and then started buzzing around with it
and I think oh well we did the coachella
joint we just asked them to buy one and
they just took that out of the budget
jeremy got that over and then ana drum
machine in atlanta for show I just
wanted I had done a show in a while and
so I just wanted one backstage to play
with it so clean that's highly that
would three so they sold three four or
theremins is you well the fourth one
they gave us I think the fourth one you
should get 3 by 3 you get one also
I don't think I'm definitely helping
them
yes but you definitely with just on this
I don't know [ __ ] about a theremin but
yeah if I walked as my grandma's you may
notice yeah hey girl I just posted a
boomerang of a Hannibal doing one today
and there's a couple of comments like
that's it I'm going I'm going to go get
one I'm getting one and they hear this
[ __ ] you often get like you often get
like messages or tweets like what is
that where'd you get that
what do you know if it's worth more than
the prize about how many people have
never heard of our theremin I suppose
enough I could work on my finger exactly
so Sony alright they sold for theremin
this year the past two years they sell
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I wonder what
other instrument is out that I could get
something weird I mean that's easy to
learn or something that you want to
invest time into learning uh well is
this this look even automated yet yeah
you just gotta find the right but get to
getting make a bang out of it and take
some technique you got to get only like
an [ __ ] yes I did
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]
riding down the street in the van
looking for the [ __ ] man cuz
they gave me a parking ticket I got a
finger and I'm bout to click it go the
Parsons get some chicken rub it on your
face now using this get man these
napkins are so good pickup us home from
the table
it's a theremin rap showing hey what the
theorem and kept go hey so for this year
[Music]
mmm ah okay
it's alright that's relaxants
therapeutic so not crazy what else you
been up to man you've been travelling
around now just left a desert yesterday
went to the woods this place called feel
more California yeah when I feel with my
lady jumped in the river
you know man got bitten by some spiders
together you know that's romantic when
you get bit together y'all both we ready
when I was Airbnb and the guy and his
wife stayed at Eddie old couple they
stayed in this back room outside of the
house but it was attached to the house
it was weird is where we will take
mushrooms and like old people show up
and they CH are they trying to be those
type of Airbnb hosts hood you guys we
right over here if you need anything at
first because somebody whoever manage
the property is gone they had to stay
there and you got to drive through a
creek just to get for the house yeah
it's one of those those weird don't
properties but you got 300 acres to
yourself Wow
we got a river you got a river you got
wood and I was there and then well I was
here before there and then I had another
MV situation oh and uh Joshua tree
yeah what the Joshua tree we just did
straight off the grid no phone service
no internet it's just you and whatever
noise you was a dope that was dealt to
went to an agent's house for ages or
yesterday her agent
you have a house out there young dude
that got property out in the desert you
know me now use the house with him
percent had up I know that means because
it's a movie it's like directors it
ain't all medians down so his 10% is a
big champion you know I mean like so
that was dope
didn't you say you went on a spiritual
journey in a sense yeah when I was
growing up was tell us about that
journey that you take which one I took a
few of yeah of the mushrooms ticket and
where did you go well I went how was
that tell me something about that
because it you briefly told me that you
did some mushrooms in the desert so uh
what's the what was your experience
because everyone has a different
experience
well um it got and he lived real fit in
the driver's seat and then I realized
some people say that me god when they
eat mushrooms do you really feel like
you met God yeah I felt like I met the
Creator he let me sit in the driver's
seat and then I realized like oh I am to
create it and so are you you know you
got I'm God the handle was God yeah I
felt like I could elaborate on that
what do you mean like we we all
connected yeah we're all connected okay
Tony
and if that's the case say gods the
ocean yeah then we're waves she had like
this existential experience yeah
everything was one everything was one of
the plants I couldn't step on a plant
out there I feel like I was stepping on
something that I
did you get the everything that's like
plants fell greener and brighter did you
see that yeah I did see that and I
didn't step on them but also woodsy rock
formations look like people were like
happy people or scared people depending
on where I was mentally like if I felt
like I had a lot of power and I wanted
to rule [ __ ] in the stones the
structures how much did you eat you
remember I don't know I remember fasting
before you ate mushrooms yeah yeah yeah
I fasted before because I was going for
that spiritual yeah journey she fasted
for a day or two they're not like twelve
hours 12 hours for and so that when you
it's the first time you ever done
shrooms redone yeah the first time so
how long did it take before they kicked
them like an hour not just a second time
adentro nothing that really happened the
first time I got horny okay it's the
second time it took like an hour and a
half to kick in yeah did you get like
the weird anxiety in the four accounts
yeah I feel weird I definitely felt like
I was gonna throw up or something yeah
yeah when I broke through I was calm it
was yeah it was shooting stars out there
I saw the Milky Way they're helping
sacred geometric patterns in the sky
okay so you got some good vision I was
able to move clouds with my hand what
yeah just to look up at the sky just
blow you blow like you blow a kiss in
the sky and it like the clouds move out
of the way those were the clouds homey
animals desert though at night you can
still see that's beautiful I know that's
hot that's that sounds like the most
ideal way it was a hyperbola so it was
gone we knew it was gonna be shooting
stars at night and we knew that the moon
was gonna be so bright that you was
gonna look like he was on a movie set
just walking through the desert
everything that's good portable food and
the stars were so bright that you could
see the Milky Way you can see like one
part of the sky just was full like a
lines it's full of stars you know dang
oh so you're quite over and I got
calling that loop the infinity loop
being what is that that's when you time
travel light as present in the future
become one when time perception gets
weird yeah I know you're tripping balls
you and a
like in there before by every step you
take forward leads you to the next step
how long of a trip was this this whole
of this trip lasted maybe like maybe
like 12 hours whoa whoa you ain't a we
stayed up sunset we stayed up the whole
night
we know just wait a lot cuz usually a
mushroom trips like six hours well it
depends did you keep eating them or just
one trip lasted that long I think I
think I took another bump during the
night yeah and we just stayed up all
night caught the sunrise whoa and like
this hot to a little hot tub outside
damn who's talking [ __ ] you know me it
is the most ideal version of doing
mushrooms and I took notes yeah I
documented the whole thing there's no
ski because you don't take mushrooms and
like walk around Bonnaroo that's the
ride that's the wrong way to do it your
nature
look at that that was yeah not a good
idea not the same person that was before
2/3 or like a house party oh I've done
that before eight rooms went to a house
partying like well I have talked about
here why are these people here why is
there so much electricity in here you
can hear electricity electricity sucks
when you're [ __ ] shrooming you can
hear the electricity you can hear that
can hear within a whiles you can hear
like I felt like I was in I felt like
you feel you become a spirit you know
yes got a man you don't let you feel
everything you feel like you're in a
body right like your body feel like a
suit like you in a space field imitating
yeah and at first it was like it's hard
to walk in this suit and you and I felt
like because it's the desert you'll know
if you at them like you'll know hear
them again at a time or you now are you
in the future that make sense because at
one point I felt like we crash-landed on
this planet with sound future risk
but we did it millions of years ago
which means you got a adapt to this
planet all over again
and then I felt like we inhabited this
planet and we have to live and reproduce
on this planet running heaven that
pretty much that's past present and
future is one and that's what I'm that's
what I experienced yeah yeah I never
tripped that hard I fears the Holy
Trinity I'm sure I've tripped that hard
but on acid not on shrooms I've never
gone to that level on shrooms but uh I
definitely gotten there on ketamine
before yeah you know oh [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah I'm looking at I'm just looking at
what I documented now which all you need
this a couple of these notes I was like
there's a fight within with it
but once I allow it I become one with it
I am it uncontrollable does that make
sense I say that again there's a fight
with them with it but once I allow it I
become one with it I am it that makes
sense I control it that makes sense
whether that's fear or whatever knock
your fear I don't think over I think
it's more you understanding the trip
because once you let the trip take over
and let it let it do its thing and you
stop fighting it that's when you can
gain control that's what I'm ready to
see the vision and stuff like a clear
because I realized that I am fear
exactly the place of fear then I was
able to control here acceptance is the
hardest part of tripping like like being
like okay
I'm tripping balls and I gotta accept
this and ride the wave that's I think
that's hardest part I think that's what
a lot of [ __ ] wake out on that
[ __ ]
yes I said we all admire her then or it
then I become it Cheers
are they
yeah damn and shop well that's good man
I feel like you found yourself over the
past few days strong shot yep
down myself jacking off in the desert
yeah why would you do that you just
ruined a really good story
hmm you know why he was jacking off in a
desert [ __ ] out here trying to [ __ ] a
lizard a little bit have some beautiful
little I want to take over the desert
that the second time I did shrooms in
the desert mm-hmm I end up pulling my
meat out consumption starts in my loins
like my loins is catch fired I feel real
turned on such as got to touch myself
ever I know the shrooms are kicking in
some people get that's weird sure not
because mama get upset you just get a
boner I don't get a boner is just
something like got at edges guy just
gotta touch it like something put it in
something to touch something I've never
heard of that before but you know what I
don't judge you a few days I just jumped
in the river like it just I just want to
be in something you know I mean
interesting only for that feeling when I
did execute before well here's what I
will say I've been to a couple parties
with poles with Byron and he you get
right in the Pope he is from Africa
Thimphu he get you get right in the pool
I think I had when I read it I rented
that house in LA was a crazy party I
think maybe some people swim later but
you got that early and he had the
snorkel and [ __ ]
I got I got fans
I got snuggled got massive hampers -
yeah
I got the hook I upgraded I got the
boost you put all the swim boo-yeah
professional and of the stands that go
over the boots
BAM you take your swimming serious there
is not that because nobody else was out
at least somebody's using this goddamn
pool yeah yeah every time this guy gets
an Airbnb he's like hell yeah it's got a
pool and we never use it
I never saw ever I mean I just liked the
idea of the having a pool having a pool
I don't think I quoted of having a pool
party the option of having a pool party
but then realizing I don't want that
many people in my place yeah because I
don't like that me people in a space now
I like to go to a party but I don't want
to deal with the because I don't think
it's tough to enjoy your party if it's
cause you like are they breaking this
that I do an inhale what's going on yeah
so it's tough to cuz you're managing the
party you got their promoter instead of
yeah that's true yeah you can still have
but it's not the same type of fun it's a
switch you have to you just become older
you don't want it like I don't want to
talk to nobody other party yeah I know
what I would want to do yeah swim hard
nobody when you swim exactly you're out
of the water and when you got on a
snorkel you wouldn't have to come up
there the whole boys say I know what a
whole water good strategy I have a price
go get a girl I don't eat it
get back back in the water snow I was
gonna say because snorkeling is more for
like looking at aquatics and stuff but
for you it's about isolation what yeah
then left alone and you can swim - I
respect I respect that espíritu though I
respect that
yeah I can't hate on that I'm saying
like great things on the water
cuttlefish yeah you know oh I love
snorkeling man I love snorkeling there's
a hole in the world of it well it's like
you know you're literally like you know
I'm obviously I'm obsessed with like
fish and aquariums but what I love about
snorkeling is like you just in a giant
aquarium looking at all this beautiful
coral reefs and all kinds of funky but I
slum next next to a barracuda last time
I was in Mexico yeah this is a
terrifying now with a million what would
swim girl is one pill the mixing would
swim - utter my mother was trying to
yeah not that Lina
that barracudas is scary you ever see
what a barracuda looks like I've seen
yeah it's very I have a Ranbir one in
the ocean and Hawaii I ran upon some
some huge black long it was the size of
meat yeah but Turtles was like turtles
yeah but for the cuttlefish sea turtles
was like some of the most majestic
beautiful things I've smelled it like a
half like 40 minutes of just you know
just following these animals man and and
I think the turtles will Joe is he
following us is that a man yeah they do
think yeah they they would look back
then they would just take off and I was
swimming kept it with me gang there are
new terms a sense of humor I was
swimming with two turtles I was in
Hawaii and one turtle like people start
to come up to the turtle right and try
to pet it in the shallow water so one
turtle bit to other turtle in the ass
right and then the other turtle looked
around and who the [ __ ] bit me and
stared at me like like what did you bite
me in my ass yeah in the other terms
that swim by he like I got you and then
I didn't swimming together I was like oh
man look at these [ __ ] turtles
you know one of my homies don't know I
actually had a funny story and it
involved acid he took acid and he went
up he went I think he went scuba diving
on acid I want to do this [ __ ] and yeah
he can't he came up on a cuttlefish and
I guess he had this moment with this
cuttlefish I guess they were like going
back in there and it was coming towards
them who's changing colors is doing
whatever they say we're having like this
weird exchange and he was like dude that
cuttlefish knew I was on some [ __ ] and
it's like a good feel of energy yeah and
he said that they were just kind of like
chill and going back and forth like keep
people communicating somehow okay no
okay okay you you what you're trying to
communicate to me is that listen to the
homies the story that was on the past
about how yeah him in that service they
were the fish were bobbing out hey I
ain't as intrusive you know what let
them let him let them have a story it's
my story they're gonna matter story look
I'm okay
look I was in the Dominican Republic
right yeah yeah and I'm in the water and
I hear something that's like like a hot
pitch like noise like that yeah
and I look it is like 15 cuttlefish yeah
in a weird diagonal line side-by-side
yeah and I'm swimming close to him as I
can but I'm in snorkel mask song he go
down so far and it was the most
beautiful thing and think they wouldn't
think like the ocean is moving they were
still it was just in the line they were
just in a line but it was going diagonal
line and it was like weird to run up on
it cuz I'm like are you jellyfish it
took me a while to realize that
cuttlefish and I couldn't even capture
that moment were they like changing
colors and stones and they weren't
really change the colors but they were
just there and it was so they like
aliens they were just such a formation
the beautiful water beautiful creatures
yeah and they rare they'd rather see
because I went out to finally and I
couldn't see him yeah
now we were losing Japan me and my
cousins on acid Nicky big dick yeah you
know me Nick Nick in the system now he'd
get out soon hopefully and by someone I
mean four to ten years uh good luck Nick
I love like we gained ich Astrid for the
first time wrong in this part and me and
Nick we was out and Nick was
communicating with his bird and the bird
would look at him and Nick was just
focusing on his bird and the bird would
look at him and then take two hops and
contours them and look at him again and
I'm watching this [ __ ] and to the point
where Nick realized what he was doing
and he got embarrassed and he looked at
me
and I just saw laughs I know what he was
doing he's like good
I will communicate with that bird I know
I can see you doing that violin disturb
you
yeah there's a big tough look at dude so
you got to imagine that too as part of
the story he's locked in on the bird and
they were look at each other yeah the
birds look at him and he's taking those
little bird hops to him and I was like
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
the bird man I'm up to denilla and so he
got embarrassed yeah it was a point when
you were after you realized like what
the [ __ ] about doing can't be verified
yeah you gotta embrace it I communicated
with a bee once on mushrooms
that's all be sitting on a like the side
of a bike and I was looking at him he's
looking at me we locked for a second and
then I just kind of like I felt the
energy felt my energy kind of came up
close and it kind of flew towards me and
I'm like I'm not [ __ ] with that being
locked away but I felt like I could feel
like it's like there was like this
pulsating energy coming from this be you
know like shooting at me I could feel it
there's always a part of you like
although I cycle this year yeah exactly
if you to continue ain't no telling what
what happened exactly it's a fear of
that mm-hmm is the fear of getting close
and becoming one with that be yeah well
you broke through you're saying yeah I
mean not yes the fear of that like what
would happen if this bit will just be
going my mouth will I become a beat
whatever thoughts you have yeah you bet
you'd be like man I'm trippin man let me
not [ __ ] with this be no more also you
don't want to get too close and then
have that be break your heart or just
thinking
[Music]
ha ha ha Salafi ha ha ha
I'm gonna be able to give a sport my boy
i'm a boy with the neighbours bored
beautiful with a keeper boys yeah
episode is gonna be a tricky one
Colorado another one that you eat
mushrooms and listen to yeah this is
gonna be the let's get into first are
you riding a car right now
make a left turn this is large it is a
hot new singing just gracious and
bodacious good great dance bodacious
it's getting hot in here that's exactly
where is weapons out the presentence
others there's hiding here
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good good good
[Music]
Oh too many toys very good part that we
get out of control it's fun now
well oh my god hey if you're driving a
car right now
hit the brakes put it in reverse make a
lift Oh again and then bite your rip you
there you know
for you by
Wow
cold gas you
[Laughter]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
by
ah you
[Music]
oh-oh-oh
which describe particles during the fire
[Music]
hey you know this week's episode on the
handsome Rambler is brought to you by
five for club looking good doesn't need
to cost a fortune and five for club is
revolutionize in the way men shout each
month they send you a curated box of two
to three items or a hand-picked to match
the current season in your individual
style they've been helping them with
fashion for 15 years and they already
shipped over a hundred thousand men each
month five fold Club can help you build
your wardrobe one month at a time you
get a hundred and twenty dollars worth
clothes for just 60 bucks a month you
can pause the cancel anytime there's no
commitment baby you could just say hey I
got a lot of service this month uncle
I'm going shell and then we're your
couple months can come back and get more
shirts so head to five for club calm and
that's a promo code Rambler and they'll
give you 50% off your first month
package plus a free pair of sunglasses
so you could look cool like me that's
50% off your first package at 5-4 club
and you've got a spell you got to spell
it out fi ve fo you are club.com and put
that promo code in rambling get 50% off
look cool
[Music]
she was talking about the spider-man
[ __ ] yeah well yeah I mean we'll cut all
this look a lot of this [ __ ] but am I
not when I leave Holly that's it we let
it be let it be a loosey goosy you know
what oh yeah man that was great hiring a
look-alike it so-called look-alike but
in spite of anything if I'm not doing
that [ __ ] man it's really my only in my
head it was my only option that's how I
think because I couldn't make it cause I
was filming in Atlanta but to me I mean
I don't want to just miss totally miss
the spider-man premiere the spider-man
and I'm at it I'm in three things I want
to be there in some way the sauce
thought I should send somebody there
then the malicious way not to make fun
anybody that's what that was my explicit
direction to him was be chilled gonna be
weird don't do just be there and be
normal somebody ask you questions answer
the questions hi how you think I would
answer them just be cool and [ __ ] take
pictures and just play it cool but I
never get some blog coverage and then I
would have the pictures for my own
laughs and I'll be able to post them but
I didn't know this [ __ ] was going to go
insane viral and also it's funny to see
in the various levels of reaction
because they didn't went from my just
goofy prank I put about maybe 30 minutes
into when what others write articles all
the the the problem with it and people
think black people look alike and I took
to kind of the fun out of this thing was
just because I wanted to just I thought
it'd be funny for I thought it'd be
funny if I couldn't make it and you send
somebody also the questions he said what
I would have said yeah everything that's
here than any other carpet even had a
mountain
risen down because he had the ability
mouth he's a big fan of yours he
actually was my stand-in um when I did a
video for the MTV Movie Awards
they had him as my stand-in okay and
even then I wasn't you bit tall for my
standing or whatever I'll allow it
and but so i reaiiy sent out the tweet
asking for some people and it was a
couple people that look like me use a
bunch of white people that were emailing
me here kind of clogging the box a
little bit and and then he reached out
and I said yeah you know just cuz I
already work with him I know he he you
know it's been on sets before some other
[ __ ] might just do some weird
crazy [ __ ] I know he'd be able to play
it cool and then that [ __ ] I was on set
we were watching him it was me and Jay
Johnson and they watched him on
Instagram live it was like watching an
action thriller I this guy was he was in
the car
yeah you guys I'm doing you know about
to go to the premiere he talked himself
up like trying to get himself hype there
was only six people watching that [ __ ]
on live and [ __ ] but we like watch that
[ __ ] and shake it myself like because
I'm thinking he's not gonna get in
actually because I'd asked him if I
could do it they said no and then I told
him I said they said we can't do
anything about to go anywhere alright
alright let's try it but I didn't think
he was gonna get on the carpet but he
was willing to try so you know and he
got on the carpet man he and other
question that [ __ ] was so funny I was
dying laughing well you was what cuz he
went into he went in to get some gym
teachers they were kind of tough on me
yeah I was like oh snap you got a
professional yeah it was pretty uh
genius that's insane how many times and
I would say yeah he acted but it's just
like that's the thing to own these
carpets is not much to say that's why I
mean now I know I won't do the same
thing go
a forward at the carpet but I know now
I'll switch it up in some way to make it
because I've done those words you try to
make me say something funny but it's
none of those no red carpet interview
I've done on my own has ever moved the
needle in any way you go look on YouTube
my Baywatch carpet interviews 400 views
here 500 years therefore this [ __ ] like
it's nothing usually crazy [ __ ] doesn't
happen on the carpet so you get five
hundreds of Baywatch what at 500 views
but certain outlets when you do it about
20 something on a cookie through there
you could do that just walking down the
street you could be more than that oh
maybe spider-man brought of you did you
did you get like positive feedback from
Sony for that today were they like hey I
told you not to do that what no because
it didn't I mean it was good for them
ultimately wasn't it good for everybody
yeah um no no I mean nothing direct to
me it's promotes to move that's why she
gets promoted even my dad [ __ ] heard
about it yeah you said your dad called
you yeah I did call me like in the
morning and he just like uh so you know
he doesn't understand English the bear
will put your hand boobers and then
something about spider-man and he saw
some random black dude he's met Hannibal
bunch of times he's like what the [ __ ]
is going on he thought something was
wrong if anything usually I don't repeal
not a had gout I said he was s roll up
project sign on my dad with the you
don't know what the [ __ ] spider-man is
so I had to explain to him what
spider-man is and then I'd explained
with him the stunt and why it was funny
and he just was lost like a 45-minute
Converse lost he was like whatever
wonder 45 minutes could even understand
what's going on or y'all was speaking
and broken english it was a little bit
of everything we you know the language
OH - B yeah I speak Korean by speaking
in like a second grade level [ __ ] you
know really and he speak English in a
second grade level so imagine two second
graders trying to explain what the
hell's going on there's evidence four to
five
for five minutes first you gotta figure
out what spider-man is exactly a good
man fighter who knows Joe yeah
the craziest part is Inside Edition
running up on his house yeah I thought
it yeah yeah that's where what are y'all
doing running on the phone in I think he
was on the phone as I was pulling on I
was walking somewhere who they are
sharpening Outsiders naked on the
[ __ ] - loose on edition am inside
edition hello
oh my lesson host makes yeah he is I
just walked up on his do or go did you
will was out of a why could he do it
this is not yeah this is about a be sent
in a person to a premiere about the
eighth movie about a fake person they
got bitten by a radioactive spider in a
comic book I hope people took that but
it was crazy that email that you
forwarded me to show me like all the
news outlets that picked it up yeah that
was in the sanity like that wasn't
everything and that wasn't even
everything that was like do that list
just kept going and have you had that
much [ __ ] like when's the last time
you've had the most coverage over some
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
how long you know me [ __ ] like that
anyways yeah no that was that yeah that
was a good move genius genius tiara move
but uh yeah I'm excited too
I'm going to see the movie since I gonna
see it here in Chicago with my uh taking
my niece and nephew oh they don't stay
in town
my nephew wrote me a letter like saying
you need to take you if you and Chicago
do something with Grandma and granddad
either take them out or protect them the
shoes - granddad need some help with him
shoot with his shoes get him some
Jordans you going off in his let it was
great
slow down young man Jordan do not fit
old people will it don't he's just
thinking about himself he like Georgia
so you think my sixty Jordan only we're
joining them on issues that straps on
absord with Stacy Adams is [ __ ] Stacy
Adam athletic addition nine jordan says
Jordan work very little yeah Wedgwood
house once Adam joining with type of
issues Tiger Woods got an awesome time
we were all JC's and am
oh they wear Bruce Lee shoes to these in
prison and that's what always here I got
in pretty goes I think you're still
chart I think you're still stuck in that
mushroom movie see the world of the loot
oh they on the same all described
exactly Oh blue
yeah man
Esther specialist yeah I was everything
crazy stop that
kicking it with little rail second year
in a row it's crazy
was he performing up there he just go
out there he just he's went out there to
think it went out there last minute the
thing was the same thing last year why I
hit him up like I'm about to go I was in
Atlanta
yeah last year I'm about the head of
essence I think I saw Tiffany posted
something about being there let's go
down and do it yeah let me kick it kick
it with Tiffany I mean I make up any why
go we're going at it for people just go
for no reason I mean it's not no reason
to [ __ ] concert shows this good
energy but all right it's like old music
right like Darren whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
uh that's some of those act but chance
performed okay the lines before
Oh No Limit reunion no liquor yeah sorry
it's uh not even spell right I know how
to say no with any part of it see murder
wasn't it Oh shackles did Master P that
they go crazy when they did make him say
ah I was to be honest I was in the
bowels of the building slumped off
wandering around somewhere
okay this guy he's [ __ ] around
high of he'll to the end of the Red Hot
Chili Peppers set at Bonnaroo just to
hear give it away but he couldn't stick
around from make him say on why didn't I
was different hahaha but they did kill
give it away he did kill give it away he
was hitting the head playing it away he
was hitting booze in it come on come on
come on give it away far away the way he
was hidden it yeah give it away give it
up so that was totally worth waiting for
by the way that is especially do
fireworks doing that [ __ ] and they did
fireworks burn that [ __ ] are you red are
Chili Peppers man man that's what made
me to start listening to other music
okay fair enough
all right like it was them then it was
like a group called Linkin Park
oh they were terrible I didn't know that
at the time yeah a little biscuit
everybody got into some [ __ ] yeah
young girl who knew you not me
I knew you knew because you'd probably
call see strongly listen to music your
whole life like that type of music not
that I like MC Hammer use he sucked
now having so and the lice well I
definitely sucked he doesn't leave it he
up on the South that's um yeah I'm
running sound that's southern music
you know some others took vandalizing I
mean we were so he's back was hidden
really at the party shirt yeah and I
baby I'm just holding with [ __ ] else but
oh he had a men thought he'd end up like
a rap ninja yeah they totally just
golden in judo
[Music]
let's go [ __ ] you Tom out any sell real
estate now still getting that push maybe
flip it now right all right now that
might be my next I want ours I thought
about doing that
a house flipping show but I'm not happy
at all so maybe I think with this fake
like I'm out to do some [ __ ] and then
just cut to it being done how did that
[ __ ] ever again I'll come job all that
drywallers [ __ ] but we got it done now
if I could calculate it I think the
value of his houses went up about
$20,000 let's put it on the market and
then we got and my Spanish has gotten
better for some reason alone I have
invented you know me
that's true because I like my co-founder
father's a contractor and there is a
spot not too far from you right in the
corner is a Dunkin Donuts every morning
he goes over there throw some Mexican
guys in the back of his van and they get
the job done by the end of the day
what's coming up keep doing them with
keep doing now and I guess I was a
flower
[Music]
[Music]
all right sorry
you think chicks offense or like
Coachella chick so they just out there
the [ __ ] have a good time and do
drugs but a little more like yeah I want
to get my business off the ground
um I think it's as all its it's all ages
from I think from mid-20s up up to the
60s I was in watching chance [ __ ] in the
VIP section it was this drunken older
woman that kind of took to me a little
bit but she was past her bedtime or
something and I started rolling in the
back of her head but nobody was with her
she just faded she kind of stuck to me
and so now just feel like I'm just
taking care of a drunk aunt and so but I
can't I'm not let this lady take my
night away and so she was trying to and
so I we get into the back we had access
to the the back of the Superdome and
[ __ ] and so I just handle someone [ __ ]
$60 as I can you get her somewhere
safely didn't like drop the house I am
this is when no limit was planned things
as well or did I think this might have
been right after chances said I think
she was out of there mate like for real
like so as suspense is like Lollapalooza
for black people
yeah okay yeah you go see lots of white
linen mm-hmm yeah it's definitely that
all right
44 fours you ever talk about it 44 not
we haven't got into it yet actually
James Agee album we talk about a little
bit I think you know what uh while they
enjoy bad as I saw they had a theory
that it's the fourth blueprint album
none he said he one point he said Julie
I want to rap like common sense but I
made five million I mean rapping like
common sense and this is him now finally
rapping like common maybe I was like nah
dude this year 20 years ago yeah but did
he did he give a solid explanation for
why he called for 44 he said he woke up
yeah let's put a title track he woke up
at four forty four and wrote that well
here's what I wonder did he does writing
that mean that he just cuz he famously
is known to not write his [ __ ] down he
spits it but did he actually pin the
paper this or did he just wake up and go
into the other room and just start
yelling there's definitely double
meaning I mean that's not that's I just
believe that's how jay-z works wait
there's third things is how am I like
he'd be like I'll be damned if I drink
Belvedere will puff guys a rock yeah I
feel you eat at me but at 440 is 444
like a Bible passage or something now
okay okay get that get that theory out
of the way so I really my review of the
album is I really liked it I thought it
was really good it didn't sound like
jay-z trying to be old jay-z it sounded
like a new jay-z but with a little old
sound if that makes sense which made it
new to me sounded like an independent
kind of underground album where he was
lightweight confessing some stuff on the
album there oh yeah let it go into the
details easily I'm sorry I did this baby
yeah I'm sorry and then the balls for
him to just be like and it's only going
to be a half an hour
that's pretty [ __ ] ballsy I got a
guest artist people want good music they
don't want it too it just wanted to be
the right amount of time I think I junk
about short aisles but you want if that
[ __ ] is supposed to be that amount of
time
then let it be that you know more
absolutely 44 the track 444 he made it
be four minutes 44 seconds also oh [ __ ]
I didn't know that yeah I didn't get
that deep but I gave it a couple of
listens while I was playing MLB and what
songs you like so far I like I like the
story LJ the best so far just because
like I like how hat some of it he's just
kind of talking and then he goes into a
flowy like he goes into a flow so it's
like it was so free-forming that it just
felt like it just felt like it wasn't
done before like we missed out on some
real estate deals and their song and
some paintings what well that the song
is like I bought a pain I think that's
legacy oh that no that is that is the
story of OJ raised all right there is it
don't go to my children he there are yes
I really bought a house to dump over to
me two at two years laters were two
million at twenty twenty-five me yes I
feel he's playing a better yet it was
worth 8 million damn I can't wait to I
give this [ __ ] to my children it could
have been her letting the oldest [ __ ]
bro instead we'll go sit in there that's
just cold my family whew yeah that's I
mean at all good they're all good all my
family a few you know me I was feeling
it I I don't know anyone like like oh we
got em er in here all white with no
socks nothing my favorite part of the
song like yeah random [ __ ] yeah you turn
my music up turn the vocals up turn
everything up not my settlement up tell
me
I need more theremin in my hip bone I am
that sound good
never been a negative mood for this
[Music]
eunbi setting right there check me out
in a snap understand that right there
yeah this is the tripi episode new
painting from video game Atari do they
use their ego down here
8-bit 8-bit sound is that that that yeah
that's 8-bit write down a bit
[Music]
8-bit sound basically what different
don't recall what you got yeah pretty
much like a pixelated child you don't
exam yeah hey you all are you gonna be
in pixels to the movie ah you gonna do
any lego movie ah I like to I like to
Lego movies a lot man voiceover work is
easy and smooth that Batman Lego move
was funny man man Lego they punch though
[ __ ] out that don't joke that way
hitting so hard day and it's not for
kids
the jokes ain't for kids no visuals of
the kids those jokes are adult as [ __ ]
and dark a lot I really like say one I
haven't watched anything like what for
example it's not though is how they
don't stick with you like that
yep no yeah they don't hear at a movie
and they like pace is funny this rapidly
don't you don't walk out maybe you walk
out the room repeating one but young I
couldn't float it to you you know I
remember but it's funny as [ __ ] and
sorry
alright I got a [ __ ] I haven't I
haven't seen a single lego movie but you
know why slowly to fail because I don't
I like like I like Legos I like playing
with LEGOs but I never thought of
watching a movie with Lego people well
it's kind of I mean it's just people but
as Legos you know I'm saying
so the first lego movie you watch you
just what did you watch it on never you
go to the theater say I'm not a theater
so you were like I'm gonna just smoke
this weed and I'm gonna go see this
[ __ ] Lego move for no with no
background or anything or did you hear
that it was good
awesome I really heard it was good yeah
okay all right I don't know
you're the Ventures guys so you like why
you thought about the Lego movies like
they some weird underground [ __ ] boom by
the history of Lego my history of Lego
moves we're underground who is the air
those fans a little that will make these
these weird steel movies yeah and then
Lego came out you name okay so yeah it
was a big underground cook clean he
doesn't know about that did you had up
almost nothing I know about that
mainstream rails you know but there
should I reduce to process now it's nice
right sir
you feel left out from a quality
Steakhouse mug you see the movie oh oh
man this is gonna change now to ease up
on this because you've never found
clothes many comedies up off of the
machine
[Music]
all right everything like a professional
is gonna want to cut you with what is
not gone on a side we get straight up
record a whole RFA album right now with
that machine and people will be always
happy without animals getting it what
happened what kinda sound like that well
you know now I'm Lenovo well maybe after
that whole twisted dark fantasy my
beautiful daughter a fantasy Jake
Tennessee's rod or my enemy well
remember we went and saw uh we thought
we saw the Watch the Throne tour he
[ __ ] so load on his auto-tune for
like I want that's not like it felt
familiar felt like he did it for a good
15 minutes then ever saw he just kept
going on the auto-tune uh like just up
and down just like yeah like just up and
down oh and and like you couldn't like
if you if he didn't have an altitude it
would probably be like the weirdest vibe
in the room everyone will probably just
be like what is this crazy ass yeah hang
on even what happened one second yeah
[ __ ] would be like what but he
was just going in
Oh exactly exactly
that's it that's that be a centenarian
fired right there what let's bring this
one home guys let's bring it on bring it
on home in and out the show up in the
shower you know how it goes know how we
go Shelly little low and surprises
Harmon you be careful now and the
different personal terrible but it's
kind of though but it still has some
issues but mostly it's pretty good hang
hang hang should be me Porto Rican know
what I really meant all around
- I wanna miss no issue and she can't
you got the tissues the fish you have
the tissues got the issue for the tissue
on the Popo horrible would all get onto
my day smack you with the with the rain
I am pissed claim I say [ __ ] like mr.
Baine ah Tony chair mantra sort of like
a
[Music]